The Hidden Brain. Revealing patterns of the mind. Please do not be alarmed. The adults in my life know where I am. They practice something called free range parenting. We've gone out with them. We've talked them out across the street. We've observed them.
The Hidden Brain. Revealing patterns of the mind. Please do not be alarmed. The adults in my life know where I am. They practice something called free range parenting. We've gone out with them. We've talked them out across the street. We've observed them.|||隐性大脑。揭示思维模式。请不要惊慌。我生活中的成年人知道我在哪里。他们实行一种叫做放养式育儿的理念。我们和他们一起出去过。我们和他们一起走过马路。我们观察过他们。
You know, it's not like we somehow drop them off in the middle of a jungle and said, fed for yourselves, kid. But the state has now set the Matees a letter saying what they've done is unsubstantiated child neglect. The Matees say the county's applying a law that says you can't leave a young child alone in a car or building. To them, that law can be stretched to be up anywhere, playgrounds, walking open school, and to us, that's Apple's and oranges.
You know, it's not like we somehow drop them off in the middle of a jungle and said, fed for yourselves, kid. But the state has now set the Matees a letter saying what they've done is unsubstantiated child neglect. The Matees say the county's applying a law that says you can't leave a young child alone in a car or building. To them, that law can be stretched to be up anywhere, playgrounds, walking open school, and to us, that's Apple's and oranges.|||你知道，这并不是说我们把他们扔在丛林中央然后说，孩子，自谋生路吧。但现在州政府给马蒂夫妇发了一封信，称他们的行为是未经证实的虐待儿童。马蒂夫妇则表示，县里适用了一条规定，即不能将幼儿独自留在车内或建筑物内。对他们来说，这条法律可以被延伸适用于任何地方，比如游乐场、走着去上学，而对我们来说，这完全是两码事。
Is what I'm doing messing up my kid? That's the question many parents ask, and it's the subject of today's hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vidantham and I too am a parent. The new slips we heard from W USA 9 and DC's Fox 5 local news are of the Matee family in Silver Spring, Maryland. Daniel and Alexander Matee have allowed their 10-year-old son and 6-year-old daughter to walk one mile home from a park without adult supervision. They believe in free-range parenting, and that's pretty much the opposite
Is what I'm doing messing up my kid? That's the question many parents ask, and it's the subject of today's hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vidantham and I too am a parent. The new slips we heard from W USA 9 and DC's Fox 5 local news are of the Matee family in Silver Spring, Maryland. Daniel and Alexander Matee have allowed their 10-year-old son and 6-year-old daughter to walk one mile home from a park without adult supervision. They believe in free-range parenting, and that's pretty much the opposite|||我的做法是不是把我的孩子搞砸了？这是许多父母经常问的问题，也是今天《隐性大脑》的主题。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，我也是一位家长。我们从 WUSA 9 和华盛顿特区福克斯 5 台地方新闻中听到的新片段，讲的是马里兰州银泉市的马蒂一家。丹尼尔和亚历山大·马蒂允许他们 10 岁的儿子和 6 岁的女儿在没有成人监督的情况下，从公园步行一英里回家。他们信仰放养式育儿，这几乎完全背道而驰。
of helicopter parenting. The idea is you teach your children to be independent instead of providing close supervision at all times. Parents in both camps will tell you they are simply doing their best to make good decisions for their children every day, but sometimes the decisions that parents make for children can have unintentionally negative consequences. NPR science correspondent John Hamilton recently had a story about one such parent making one such choice. I asked him to join me in the studio to talk about the story of a Tennessee mother named Juniper Russo.
of helicopter parenting. The idea is you teach your children to be independent instead of providing close supervision at all times. Parents in both camps will tell you they are simply doing their best to make good decisions for their children every day, but sometimes the decisions that parents make for children can have unintentionally negative consequences. NPR science correspondent John Hamilton recently had a story about one such parent making one such choice. I asked him to join me in the studio to talk about the story of a Tennessee mother named Juniper Russo.|||与直升机式育儿相反。这种理念是教导孩子变得独立，而不是随时提供密切监督。两个阵营的父母都会告诉你，他们只是在尽最大努力每天为孩子做出好的决定，但有时父母为孩子做出的决定可能会带来意想不到的负面后果。NPR 科学记者约翰·汉密尔顿最近报道了一个关于这样一个父母作出这种选择的故事。我请他来到演播室，和我一起聊聊田纳西州一位名叫杜松·鲁索的母亲的故事。
John, thanks for joining me. Pleasure to be here. You did this wonderful story recently for morning edition about this Tennessee mother. Can you tell me about her? Well I was interested in somebody whose views on something had changed. So this is a woman who, when she started out, she got pregnant and she wanted to do everything just perfect for her unborn child. And so she was an organic and natural. She describes herself as a crunchy mom. So she was doing all the things that crunchy moms do to try to take care of themselves and ensure
John, thanks for joining me. Pleasure to be here. You did this wonderful story recently for morning edition about this Tennessee mother. Can you tell me about her? Well I was interested in somebody whose views on something had changed. So this is a woman who, when she started out, she got pregnant and she wanted to do everything just perfect for her unborn child. And so she was an organic and natural. She describes herself as a crunchy mom. So she was doing all the things that crunchy moms do to try to take care of themselves and ensure|||约翰，谢谢你能来。很高兴能来到这里。你最近为《晨间版》节目制作了一篇关于这位田纳西州母亲的精彩报道。能跟我讲讲她吗？嗯，我对那些对某事观点发生改变的人很感兴趣。所以这是一个女人，当她刚开始怀孕时，她想为未出生的孩子把一切都做到完美。因此她崇尚有机和自然。她形容自己是一个“崇尚自然的妈妈”。所以她做着所有崇尚自然的妈妈们会做的事情，试图照顾好自己并确保
the best for their kids. And she genuinely had the best interest of her child at heart as she was doing these things. Absolutely. And when her child was born, one of the decisions she made was she didn't think she wanted to get her child vaccinated because she was concerned that vaccines might do some kind of harm to her child. Is it because there was sort of an unnatural kind of thing? They were putting in toxic and foreign substances into your body? Was that her concern? Part of it was a fear that she described of toxic substances,
the best for their kids. And she genuinely had the best interest of her child at heart as she was doing these things. Absolutely. And when her child was born, one of the decisions she made was she didn't think she wanted to get her child vaccinated because she was concerned that vaccines might do some kind of harm to her child. Is it because there was sort of an unnatural kind of thing? They were putting in toxic and foreign substances into your body? Was that her concern? Part of it was a fear that she described of toxic substances,|||给孩子最好的照顾。她在做这些事情的时候，确实是出于对孩子最好的关爱。确实如此。当她的孩子出生时，她做出的决定之一就是她不想给孩子接种疫苗，因为她担心疫苗可能会对孩子造成某种伤害。是因为觉得这是一种不自然的东西吗？它们把有毒的外来物质放进你的体内？这是她的担忧吗？部分原因正如她所描述的那样，是对有毒物质的恐惧，
bad things happening because of vaccine, but there was something else too. And I have a little piece of tape here that where she explains her point of view. I wanted to live in the kind of world where it was safe to always have babies naturally and where you could expect your children to survive to adulthood without necessarily needing modern medicine.
bad things happening because of vaccine, but there was something else too. And I have a little piece of tape here that where she explains her point of view. I wanted to live in the kind of world where it was safe to always have babies naturally and where you could expect your children to survive to adulthood without necessarily needing modern medicine.|||担心疫苗会带来不好的事情，但还有别的原因。我这里有一段录音，她阐述了自己的观点。我希望生活在这样一个世界里：在那里，始终自然生育是安全的，你可以指望你的孩子长大成人，而不一定需要现代医学。
So you can kind of hear that she wants to believe she's raising her child in a kind of utopian world. And again, this is wishing the best. And so what I find really interesting here is, of course, this is not a parent who is callous about their child. This is not a parent who is neglectful of anything. It's the opposite. It's a parent who is deeply involved and wants the best thing for their child and makes this decision that runs contrary to
So you can kind of hear that she wants to believe she's raising her child in a kind of utopian world. And again, and so what I find really interesting here is, of course, this is not a parent who is callous about their child. This is not a parent who is neglectful of anything. It's the opposite. It's a parent who is deeply involved and wants the best thing for their child and makes this decision that runs contrary to|||所以你大概能听出，她希望相信自己是在一个乌托邦似的世界里抚养孩子。再说一次，我在这里觉得非常有趣的是，当然，这并不是一个对孩子冷酷无情的父母。这不是一个对任何事情都疏忽大意的父母。恰恰相反。这是一个深度参与其中、希望给孩子最好的东西，却做出了与……相悖的决定的父母。
what public health officials tell us all the time. What public health officials say, but of course she's hearing from a group of people who are very concerned about a possible link between vaccination and autism, and she is terribly afraid that her daughter might grow up to have autism. So she decided eventually to get her child vaccinated? Yeah, and a number of things happened. She began to read the literature and questioned a little bit some of the echo chamber she was in.
what public health officials tell us all the time. What public health officials say, but of course she's hearing from a group of people who are very concerned about a possible link between vaccination and autism, and she is terribly afraid that her daughter might grow up to have autism. So she decided eventually to get her child vaccinated? Yeah, and a number of things happened. She began to read the literature and questioned a little bit some of the echo chamber she was in.|||公共卫生官员一直对我们说的话相悖。公共卫生官员是这么说的，但当然，她也听到了一群人的声音，他们非常担心接种疫苗和自闭症之间可能存在的联系，她非常害怕自己的女儿长大后会患上自闭症。所以她最终决定给孩子接种疫苗了吗？是的，发生了很多事情。她开始阅读相关文献，并开始对她身处的一些回音室效应产生了一些质疑。
But the other thing that happened was as her daughter began to get a little bit older, she started not to meet certain developmental milestones. Now she hadn't gotten vaccinated after this point. No, she had not been vaccinated up to this point. And so what Juniper knew was that there was no way vaccines could be causing any sort of problems. And it was interesting how she talked about when she first
But the other thing that happened was as her daughter began to get a little bit older, she started not to meet certain developmental milestones. Now she hadn't gotten vaccinated after this point. No, she had not been vaccinated up to this point. And so what Juniper knew was that there was no way vaccines could be causing any sort of problems. And it was interesting how she talked about when she first|||但另一件事是，随着女儿开始长大了点，她开始没有达到某些发育里程碑。此时她还没有接种过疫苗。不，直到这个时候她都还没有接种过疫苗。所以朱尼珀知道，疫苗绝对不可能引起任何类型的问题。有趣的是，她谈到自己最初是如何
learned what was going on. Here's a little piece of tape where she talks about it. I had like this immediate crisis when the doctor told me that she had developmental delays because I thought I had done everything absolutely right. And developmental delays are for those parents who do everything wrong. And so of course the irony here is that she's trying her best to protect her child and she's doing something that's in the child's best interest and it turns out not to be the case.
learned what was going on. Here's a little piece of tape where she talks about it. I had like this immediate crisis when the doctor told me that she had developmental delays because I thought I had done everything absolutely right. And developmental delays are for those parents who do everything wrong. And so of course the irony here is that she's trying her best to protect her child and she's doing something that's in the child's best interest and it turns out not to be the case.|||了解情况的。这里有一段她谈到这件事的录音。当医生告诉我女儿有发育迟缓时，我立刻陷入了危机感，因为我以为自己把每件事都做得绝对完美。而发育迟缓是那些把所有事情都做错的父母才会遇到的。所以这里的讽刺之处在于，她尽最大努力去保护她的孩子，她做的是符合孩子最大利益的事情，但结果却并非如此。
Not at all. And eventually her child did go on to get a diagnosis of autism. Now along the way, she began having the greatest thing she feared was a child with autism, and now she has one. She began to rethink two things. One was her thoughts about autism. It wasn't the terrible thing she had imagined might be, wasn't the worst thing ever. She also began to think, oh, this is not necessarily the thing that happens if you're the wrong kind of parent. And so she started to get her child vaccinated and eventually she got all caught up. So I'm fascinated by this, John, because I want to explore this larger world of how parents
Not at all. And eventually her child did go on to get a diagnosis of autism. Now along the way, she began having the greatest thing she feared was a child with autism, and now she has one. She began to rethink two things. One was her thoughts about autism. It wasn't the terrible thing she had imagined might be, wasn't the worst thing ever. She also began to think, oh, this is not necessarily the thing that happens if you're the wrong kind of parent. And so she started to get her child vaccinated and eventually she got all caught up. So I'm fascinated by this, John, because I want to explore this larger world of how parents|||完全不是这样。最终她的孩子确实被诊断出患有自闭症。在这个过程中，她最恐惧的事情发生了——她有了一个患有自闭症的孩子，而现在她真的有了。她开始重新思考两件事。一是她对自闭症的看法。它并不像她想象的那样可怕，也不是世界上最糟糕的事情。她也开始思考，哦，这不一定是你当了一个“错误的父母”才会发生的事情。于是她开始给孩子接种疫苗，最终把落下的针都补齐了。约翰，我对这一点很着迷，因为我想探讨父母如何对待……这个更大的世界。
are constantly making choices for their children. Now some parents, of course, are abusive and neglectful, but the vast majority of parents actually want to communicate the best things to their children. They're trying to communicate ethical behavior and they're trying to communicate how to be a good citizen and how to study hard and they're trying to do all these things, but sometimes the things that parents are doing can have unintended or counterproductive effects. I think that's what happens most of the time when something bad happens. I mean, I think it's pretty hard to find a parent who is not trying to do the best thing
are constantly making choices for their children. Now some parents, of course, are abusive and neglectful, but the vast majority of parents actually want to communicate the best things to their children. They're trying to communicate ethical behavior and they're trying to communicate how to be a good citizen and how to study hard and they're trying to do all these things, but sometimes the things that parents are doing can have unintended or counterproductive effects. I think that's what happens most of the time when something bad happens. I mean, I think it's pretty hard to find a parent who is not trying to do the best thing|||一直在为孩子们做出选择。当然，有些父母虐待和忽视孩子，但绝大多数父母实际上都希望把最好的东西传达给他们的孩子。他们试图传达道德行为，试图传达如何做一个好公民、如何努力学习，他们试图做所有这些事情，但有时父母所做的事情可能会产生意想不到的或适得其反的效果。我想当坏事发生时，大部分时间都是这样的。我的意思是，我觉得很难找到一个不想为孩子做最好的事情的父母。
for their child. But, depending on their information and depending on how they go about doing something, it may not turn out that way. John, thanks so much for talking with me. Delighted to be here. That was NPR Science correspondent, John Hamilton. This is the Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Feet Anthony. We all want our children to grow up to be honest. We communicate this to our kids in all kinds of ways. So parents seem to model honest behavior to their children.
for their child. But, depending on their information and depending on how they go about doing something, it may not turn out that way. John, thanks so much for talking with me. Delighted to be here. That was NPR Science correspondent, John Hamilton. This is the Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Feet Anthony. We all want our children to grow up to be honest. We communicate this to our kids in all kinds of ways. So parents seem to model honest behavior to their children.|||但根据他们掌握的信息以及他们做事的方式，结果可能并非如此。约翰，非常感谢你和我交谈。很高兴来到这里。刚才那是NPR科学记者约翰·汉密尔顿。这里是《隐性大脑》。我是尚卡尔·费特·安东尼。我们都希望我们的孩子长大后成为诚实的人。我们通过各种方式向孩子们传达这一点。因此，父母似乎在向孩子们展示诚实的行为榜样。
That's research or onion-samek, and she finds that parents want to do the right thing, but there's a catch. They tend to do that more for their daughters than for their sons. So you're saying that parents are more honest in front of their children, but you're saying that this actually might not actually be driven by both sets of children or both sons and daughters. That's right. So it's driven by girls.
That's research or onion-samek, and she finds that parents want to do the right thing, but there's a catch. They tend to do that more for their daughters than for their sons. So you're saying that parents are more honest in front of their children, but you're saying that this actually might not actually be driven by both sets of children or both sons and daughters. That's right. So it's driven by girls.|||这是研究人员安妮娅·萨梅克（Ania Samek）的研究，她发现父母想做正确的事情，但其中有一个问题。他们对女儿往往比对儿子做得更多。所以你是说父母在孩子面前表现得更诚实，但你是说这实际上可能并非由这两类孩子（即儿子和女儿）共同驱动的。没错。所以这是由女孩驱动的。
Let's back up a minute and tell you how Samak came to this conclusion. In her study, Samak wanted to see how parents behave with and without that children around. In her laboratory, she had parents play a game. So in this game, you flip two coins in private, and in this case, because we did this with children as well, we had coins that had a blue side and a green side. And so you have these two coins. If both land on green, then you're going to get a prize. Now here's the thing, the parents were free to report any outcome they wanted. You definitely can act dishonest because nobody is in the room observing you. Samak didn't watch the parents play the game, but she relied on statistics to prove whether the parents were cheating.
Let's back up a minute and tell you how Samak came to this conclusion. In her study, Samak wanted to see how parents behave with and without that children around. In her laboratory, she had parents play a game. So in this game, you flip two coins in private, and in this case, because we did this with children as well, we had coins that had a blue side and a green side. And so you have these two coins. If both land on green, then you're going to get a prize. Now here's the thing, the parents were free to report any outcome they wanted. You definitely can act dishonest because nobody is in the room observing you. Samak didn't watch the parents play the game, but she relied on statistics to prove whether the parents were cheating.|||让我们退回一步，告诉你萨梅克是如何得出这个结论的。在她的研究中，萨梅克想要看看父母在有孩子和没有孩子在身边时的行为表现。在她的实验室里，她让父母玩一个游戏。在这个游戏中，你要私下抛两枚硬币，在这种情况下，因为我们也让孩子参与了，所以我们的硬币有一面是蓝色，一面是绿色。你有这两枚硬币。如果两枚都落在绿色这一面，你就能得到一个奖品。关键是，父母可以自由报告他们想要的任何结果。你完全可以表现得不诚实，因为房间里没有人观察你。萨梅克没有观看父母玩游戏，而是依靠统计数据来证明父母是否在作弊。
We actually find that people cheat a lot, so we expect 25% of the time people will win. They actually win 40% of the time. Parents will put in situations where they could win money for themselves or win a toy for their child. Samak tested the parents with their children in and out of the room and here's where she discovered something interesting. When parents were with their daughters, they were scrupulously honest. When they were with their sons, not so much. And that's interesting because what we observe in the world is that men tend to be more dishonest than women in these games with adults, but also in various empirical evidence that's
We actually find that people cheat a lot, so we expect 25% of the time people will win. They actually win 40% of the time. Parents will put in situations where they could win money for themselves or win a toy for their child. Samak tested the parents with their children in and out of the room and here's where she discovered something interesting. When parents were with their daughters, they were scrupulously honest. When they were with their sons, not so much. And that's interesting because what we observe in the world is that men tend to be more dishonest than women in these games with adults, but also in various empirical evidence that's|||我们实际上发现人们经常作弊，所以我们预计人们有25%的时间会赢。而他们实际上赢了40%的时间。父母会被置于这样一种境地：他们可以为自己赢得金钱，或者为孩子赢得玩具。萨梅克测试了父母在孩子在房间内和房间外的情况，这就是她发现有趣的地方。当父母和女儿在一起时，他们一丝不苟地诚实。当他们和儿子在一起时，就没那么诚实了。这很有趣，因为我们在世界上观察到的是，在与成人的这些游戏中，男性往往比女性更不诚实，在收集到的各种实证证据中也是如此。
been collected. And so one thing that could be happening here is that we see a correlation. Parents, knowing that they want to transmit honest behavior to their daughters, do that and then daughters grow up to be more honest. Or parents see that it's more socially acceptable for men to be dishonest than women and then transmit honest behavior to their daughters. What's the implication of this work? I mean, when you look at parents and the behavior of parents and you look at the behavior of parents and with their children and with their sons and daughters, are there, I mean besides just being
been collected. And so one thing that could be happening here is that we see a correlation. Parents, knowing that they want to transmit honest behavior to their daughters, do that and then daughters grow up to be more honest. Or parents see that it's more socially acceptable for men to be dishonest than women and then transmit honest behavior to their daughters. What's the implication of this work? I mean, when you look at parents and the behavior of parents and you look at the behavior of parents and with their children and with their sons and daughters, are there, I mean besides just being|||因此，这里可能发生的一件事是，我们看到了一个相关性。父母知道他们想把诚实的行为传递给女儿，于是就这样做了，然后女儿们长大后变得更诚实。或者父母发现社会对男性的不诚实比对女性更宽容，然后将诚实的行为传递给女儿。这项工作有什么意义？我的意思是，当你观察父母和父母的行为，当你观察父母与孩子、与儿子和女儿在一起时的行为时，除了仅仅具有……之外，有没有
interesting, is there anything that people can say, you know, this is something that's actionable that I can take and do something with? Sure, well, I think for a long time we thought that perhaps we had honest people in the world and we had dishonest people in the world and we had dishonest people in the world. But what we see now is that context actually really matters. And we also see that if we believe the correlation goes the way that we had speculated, we see that parents' modeling behavior actually does seem to affect children. And we do observe parents that are modeling this behavior. So if anything you should make sure you act honestly in front of your
interesting, is there anything that people can say, you know, this is something that's actionable that I can take and do something with? Sure, well, I think for a long time we thought that perhaps we had honest people in the world and we had dishonest people in the world and we had dishonest people in the world. But what we see now is that context actually really matters. And we also see that if we believe the correlation goes the way that we had speculated, we see that parents' modeling behavior actually does seem to affect children. And we do observe parents that are modeling this behavior. So if anything you should make sure you act honestly in front of your|||有趣之外，还有什么人们可以说的，你知道的，这是我可以采取行动并做点什么的切实可行的事情吗？当然，嗯，我认为长期以来我们认为世界上可能既有诚实的人，也有不诚实的人。但我们现在看到的是，情境实际上真的很重要。我们也看到，如果我们相信相关性正如我们所推测的那样，我们就会发现父母的表率行为似乎确实会影响孩子。我们确实观察到父母在树立这种行为榜样。所以无论如何，你应该确保在孩子面前表现得诚实。
kids. Do you have do you have children yourself? No. Okay you don't. So I'm curious whether you behave differently or I mean even if you don't have children yourself, have you ever been in situations where you're around small kids and you feel like your behavior is changing, you feel like you need to be the upright citizen that you might not always be. All right, so I was trying to think about, we go down to these schools and we have hundreds of four-year-olds that I interact with on a daily basis running these different studies with them. One of the things that we have often is we have these programs that we randomize kids
kids. Do you have do you have children yourself? No. Okay you don't. So I'm curious whether you behave differently or I mean even if you don't have children yourself, have you ever been in situations where you're around small kids and you feel like your behavior is changing, you feel like you need to be the upright citizen that you might not always be. All right, so I was trying to think about, we go down to these schools and we have hundreds of four-year-olds that I interact with on a daily basis running these different studies with them. One of the things that we have often is we have these programs that we randomize kids|||孩子面前。你自己有孩子吗？没有。好吧，你没有。所以我很好奇你的行为是否会有所不同，或者我的意思是，即使你自己没有孩子，你是否曾身处这样一种情境：当你周围有小孩子时，你觉得你的行为正在发生改变，你觉得你需要成为一个正直的公民，而你平时可能并非总是如此。好的，所以我在想，我们去这些学校，那里有几百个四岁的孩子，我每天都与他们互动，和他们一起进行这些不同的研究。我们经常做的事情之一就是我们有这些项目，我们把孩子们随机分配到其中。
into. I actually flip a lot of coins. Kids and parents come into the school and I flip coins to determine whether certain kids will get into the preschool program that we have down in Chicago or will be in our control group. One of the ways that I can cheat is actually to misreport these cointosses. And I always feel, and I normally would not cheat
into. I actually flip a lot of coins. Kids and parents come into the school and I flip coins to determine whether certain kids will get into the preschool program that we have down in Chicago or will be in our control group. One of the ways that I can cheat is actually to misreport these cointosses. And I always feel, and I normally would not cheat|||其实我抛了很多硬币。孩子们和家长来到学校，我通过抛硬币来决定哪些孩子能进入我们在芝加哥的学前班项目，还是进入我们的对照组。我作弊的方法之一其实就是虚报这些抛硬币的结果。我总觉得，而且我平时绝不会作弊……
if it was to help myself, but I always feel like I would like to cheat to help some of these kids who I really like to get the green coin to get into these programs. But I've never actually done it. So it shows the power of society to keep me honest. Now have you, would you have, would anyone know if you cheated? I don't think so actually.
if it was to help myself, but I always feel like I would like to cheat to help some of these kids who I really like to get the green coin to get into these programs. But I've never actually done it. So it shows the power of society to keep me honest. Now have you, would you have, would anyone know if you cheated? I don't think so actually.|||如果是为了帮我自己的话，但我总觉得我很想作弊来帮助其中一些我非常喜欢的孩子拿到绿色硬币以进入这些项目。但我从来没有真正这样做过。所以这表明了社会让我保持诚实的力量。现在你，如果你作弊了，会有人知道吗？其实我觉得不会。
And it's such a tempting thing because it feels like obviously you're not, it doesn't feel like you're harming anyone. And in this case, it actually would feel like you're helping someone and that that's the temptation, isn't it? Which is actually would feel like you're helping someone and that's the temptation isn't it which is that it feels like you're doing this for a good cause and that's what makes it so so seductive. Right and I think that's where we have this moral wiggle room as well as that parents feel they don't want to be dishonest but if they're it's for a good cause they're helping their own child then they'll do things like cheat on this coin task to get a toy for their child and they may cheat on which school district they report that they're in to get
And it's such a tempting thing because it feels like obviously you're not, it doesn't feel like you're harming anyone. And in this case, it actually would feel like you're helping someone and that that's the temptation, isn't it? Which is actually would feel like you're helping someone and that's the temptation isn't it which is that it feels like you're doing this for a good cause and that's what makes it so so seductive. Right and I think that's where we have this moral wiggle room as well as that parents feel they don't want to be dishonest but if they're it's for a good cause they're helping their own child then they'll do things like cheat on this coin task to get a toy for their child and they may cheat on which school district they report that they're in to get|||这是一件非常诱人的事情，因为感觉很明显你没有，感觉你没有伤害任何人。在这种情况下，实际上会感觉你在帮助某人，而这正是诱惑所在，不是吗？实际上会感觉你在帮助某人，而这正是诱惑所在，不是吗？也就是说，感觉你是在为一个正义的事业这样做，正是这一点让它如此具有诱惑力。没错，我认为这也是我们拥有这种道德游旋余地的地方，同时父母觉得自己不想不诚实，但如果是为了一个好目的，是为了帮助自己的孩子，那么他们就会做一些事情，比如在这个抛硬币任务中作弊来为孩子争取一个玩具，他们可能会在报告自己所在的学区时作弊来进入……
into a better school and so on. Wonderful. Ania, I really want to thank you for making the time to talk with me today. This has been really wonderful and so interesting and such fascinating work. Thank you. So if you put the thing in about my desire to cheat to get people into programs, be sure you put the thing in about how I don't do it. Oh, do it. Now here's a tricky thing. I could say that I'm going to do that and then go back on my word. We are talking about cheating after all.
into a better school and so on. Wonderful. Ania, I really want to thank you for making the time to talk with me today. This has been really wonderful and so interesting and such fascinating work. Thank you. So if you put the thing in about my desire to cheat to get people into programs, be sure you put the thing in about how I don't do it. Oh, do it. Now here's a tricky thing. I could say that I'm doing that and then go back on my word. We are talking about cheating after all.|||更好的学校等等。太棒了。安妮娅，我真的很感谢你今天抽出时间和我交谈。这真的很棒，非常有趣，而且是一项迷人的工作。谢谢。所以，如果你把关于我渴望通过作弊让人们进入项目的言论写进去，一定要把我没有这样做的那部分也写进去。哦，写进去。现在这里有个棘手的事情。我可以嘴上说我要这样做，然后又食言。毕竟我们谈论的是作弊。
Wow. I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding. Yes. I have some professional integrity to guard as well. Good. Okay, good. Coming up, stop watch signs with author Daniel Pink.
Wow. I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding. Yes. I have some professional integrity to guard as well. Good. Okay, good. Coming up, stop watch signs with author Daniel Pink.|||哇。我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。是的。我也有一些职业操守需要维护。很好。好的，很好。接下来是与作家丹尼尔·平克的“秒表科学”。
We'll tell you about four parenting studies in under a minute each. After this. This is the Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantan. It's time now for another episode of Stopwatch Science. I'm joined by author and commentator Daniel Pink, Dan Hi. Hi Shankar. In Stopwatch Science, Dan and I challenge one another to talk about our favorite pieces of research in under 60 seconds.
We'll tell you about four parenting studies in under a minute each. After this. This is the Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantan. It's time now for another episode of Stopwatch Science. I'm joined by author and commentator Daniel Pink, Dan Hi. Hi Shankar. In Stopwatch Science, Dan and I challenge one another to talk about our favorite pieces of research in under 60 seconds.|||我们将用不到一分钟的时间向您介绍四项育儿研究。广告之后继续。这里是《隐性大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。现在是另一个“秒表科学”节目的时间。和我在一起的是作家兼评论员丹尼尔·平克，丹，你好。嗨，尚卡尔。在“秒表科学”中，丹和我互相挑战，在60秒内谈论我们最喜欢的研究成果。
Can it be done? We're going to find out, we also have a couple of props in the studio. I have an iPhone that's going to run a timer on Dan as he talks, and if he exceeds his minute as he is frequently prone to do, this is what he's going to hear. I'm trying to find the most irritating children's toy that I could find at home, and so that's what I brought in this studio. And I think he's succeeded. Great, wonderful. So today we're going to be talking about all the ways in which parents influence their children, but not always for good.
Can it be done? We're going to find out, we also have a couple of props in the studio. I have an iPhone that's going to run a timer on Dan as he talks, and if he exceeds his minute as he is frequently prone to do, this is what he's going hear. I'm trying to find the most irritating children's toy that I could find at home, and so that's what I brought in this studio. And I think he's succeeded. Great, wonderful. So today we're going to be talking about all the ways in which parents influence their children, but not always for good.|||这能做到吗？我们拭目以待。我们在演播室里还准备了一些道具。我有一部iPhone，会在丹说话时为他计时，如果他像往常一样经常超时，他就会听到这个声音。我试图在家里找到最烦人的儿童玩具，这就是我带到演播室里的东西。我想他成功了。太棒了，太好了。所以今天我们将讨论父母影响孩子的所有方式，但并非总是朝着好的方向。
Dan, if you're ready, your first minute starts now. OK, so this is a study from Nicholas Sim, at the University of Adelaide in Australia, Sim is an economist. And this study could be published in, if there were such a journal, the annals of bad parenting ideas. So he's how it goes.
Dan, if you're ready, your first minute starts now. OK, so this is a study from Nicholas Sim, at the University of Adelaide in Australia, Sim is an economist. And this study could be published in, if there were such a journal, the annals of bad parenting ideas. So he's how it goes.|||丹，如果你准备好了，你的第一分钟现在开始。好的，这是一项来自澳大利亚阿德莱德大学尼古拉斯·西姆的研究，西姆是一位经济学家。如果存在这样一本期刊的话，这项研究完全可以发表在《糟糕育儿点子年鉴》上。他是这样描述的。
He went to Singapore. Now Singapore is a heavily Chinese culture. And in Chinese cultures, there's a lot of respect for zodiac signs. Some signs, for instance, the year of the dragon are auspicious. Others less auspicious. And so parents actually try to have kids born in the year of the dragon. As soon as to give, absolutely. Actually actually fertility spikes in years of the dragon. It's a crazy chart.
He went to Singapore. Now Singapore is a heavily Chinese culture. And in Chinese cultures, there's a lot of respect for zodiac signs. Some signs, for instance, the year of the dragon are auspicious. Others less auspicious. And so parents actually try to have kids born in the year of the dragon. As soon as to give, absolutely. Actually actually fertility spikes in years of the dragon. It's a crazy chart.|||他去了新加坡。新加坡是一个深受中国文化影响的地方。在中国文化中，人们对生肖有很多敬意。有些生肖，例如龙年，是吉祥的。其他的则不那么吉祥。因此，父母实际上会努力生一个龙年宝宝。为了给予……完全是这样。事实上，龙年的生育率会出现飙升。这是一个疯狂的图表。
And so parents are trying to give their kids an edge. I want my kid to be born in the year of the dragon. Right. Well, Sim looked at this and he found out that there is a dramatic, pretty significant dragon effect. Wow. The kids born in the year of the dragon do worse. Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, that's not, that everybody else, and the reason for that
And so parents are trying to give their kids an edge. I want my kid to be born in the year of the dragon. Right. Well, Sim looked at this and he found out that there is a dramatic, pretty significant dragon effect. Wow. The kids born in the year of the dragon do worse. Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, that's not, that everybody else, and the reason for that|||所以父母们都在努力给他们的孩子创造优势。我希望我的孩子在龙年出生。没错。西姆研究了这一点，他发现存在一个惊人的、非常显着的“龙年效应”。哇。龙年出生的孩子表现更差。天哪，天哪，这不是，比其他人……原因在于
is that there's a premium to a university education. And so there's so many kids born in the year of the dragon. Oh, there's so many kids born in the year of the dragon that there's incredible competition for university spaces. So a lot of dragon kids don't get in, and therefore their earnings are lower. So what you want is you want to have a kid in the year of the monkey.
is that there's a premium to a university education. And so there's so many kids born in the year of the dragon. Oh, there's so many kids born in the year of the dragon that there's incredible competition for university spaces. So a lot of dragon kids don't get in, and therefore their earnings are lower. So what you want is you want to have a kid in the year of the monkey.|||大学教育有很高的溢价。由于龙年出生的孩子太多了。哦，龙年出生的孩子实在太多了，以至于大学名额的竞争异常激烈。所以很多“龙宝宝”没能考上大学，因此他们的收入也较低。所以你真正想要的是生一个猴年宝宝。
So in other words, when everyone's zigs, you want a zag. And precisely. It's like this talk market, when everyone's buying, you want to be careful, when everyone's fearful, you want to be getting in. It's exactly the same with kids. You got it exactly right. To me, it's like parenting meets economics meets game theory.
So in other words, when everyone's zigs, you want a zag. And precisely. It's like this talk market, when everyone's buying, you want to be careful, when everyone's fearful, you want to be getting in. It's exactly the same with kids. You got it exactly right. To me, it's like parenting meets economics meets game theory.|||换句话说，当所有人都在向左走时，你想要向右走。完全正确。这就像股市一样，当所有人都买入时，你要小心；当所有人都感到恐惧时，你要进场。育儿完全是一回事。你完全说对了。对我来说，这就像是育儿学遇上了经济学，再遇上了博弈论。
It's a wonderful study, and I was also born in the year of the dragon which explains my meager professional performance well speaking of uh... some choices beginning other choices i'm now handing over the buzzer and the timer to dan okay i hope he will be kinder to me than i was to him and i will not so here we go your time shank, for your one minute starts right now. All right, so this is also a study that comes to us from Australian researchers, funnily enough, this research looks at the behavior of young Australian drivers.
It's a wonderful study, and I was also born in the year of the dragon which explains my meager professional performance well speaking of uh... some choices beginning other choices i'm now handing over the buzzer and the timer to dan okay i hope he will be kinder to me than i was to him and i will not so here we go your time shank, for your one minute starts right now. All right, so this is also a study that comes to us from Australian researchers, funnily enough, this research looks at the behavior of young Australian drivers.|||这是一项很棒的研究，而且我也是在龙年出生的，这就很好地解释了我微薄的职业表现。说到……一些选择引发另一些选择，我现在要把蜂鸣器和计时器交回给丹了，好的，希望他对我会比我对他的更好，而我不会……所以，开始吧，尚卡尔，你的一分钟现在开始。好的，这也是一项来自澳大利亚研究人员的研究，有趣的是，这项研究探讨了澳大利亚年轻司机的行为。
Now very much like young American drivers, young Australian drivers sometimes take unnecessary risks on the road. And the researchers try to find out what causes the drivers to take these risks. And they find not surprisingly that context matters. If you're surrounded by a lot of peers who take a lot of risks, you're more likely to be a risky driver. Now that's not particularly surprising. The thing that I found really interesting was that the driver's parents seem to have a really powerful role in what kind of driver you become and there's a gender aspect of this young women tend to drive like their mothers young men tend to drive
Now very much like young American drivers, young Australian drivers sometimes take unnecessary risks on the road. And the researchers try to find out what causes the drivers to take these risks. And they find not surprisingly that context matters. If you're surrounded by a lot of peers who take a lot of risks, you're more likely to be a risky driver. Now that's not particularly surprising. The thing that I found really interesting was that the driver's parents seem to have a really powerful role in what kind of driver you become and there's a gender aspect of this young women tend to drive like their mothers young men tend to drive|||就像年轻的美国司机一样，澳大利亚的年轻司机有时也会在路上冒不必要的风险。研究人员试图找出是什么导致司机冒这些风险。不出所料，他们发现情境很重要。如果你身边环绕着许多喜欢冒险的同龄人，你更有可能成为一个冒险的司机。这并不是特别令人惊讶。我发现真正有趣的是，司机的父母似乎在决定你成为什么样的司机方面发挥了非常强大的作用，这里还有一个性别方面的因素：年轻女性的开车风格往往像她们的母亲，年轻男性的开车风格往往像……
like that that's now this is a small study i don't know if you can extrapolate this internationally but what this does mean is that if you pull over a teenager you know the cop shouldn't just say can i have your license in registration please the cop should say can i get the name of your dad so i can give him a call. Oh, I made it. I made it. I made it. That's just under the wire. Oh my gosh.
like that that's now this is a small study i don't know if you can extrapolate this internationally but what this does mean is that if you pull over a teenager you know the cop shouldn't just say can i have your license in registration please the cop should say can i get the name of your dad so i can give him a call. Oh, I made it. I made it. I made it. That's just under the wire. Oh my gosh.|||像……这是一项小型研究，我不知道这是否可以推广到国际上，但这确实意味着，如果你拦下一个青少年，你知道，警察不应该只说“请出示你的驾照和行驶证”，警察应该说“能告诉我你爸爸的名字吗，好让我给他打个电话”。噢，我做到了！我做到了！我做到了！刚好在最后关头。天哪。
That's like the ball going through the net as the seconds take off the clock. That was impressive. That was swish. That's interesting. So sort of what you're suggesting because we hear a lot about driverless cars these days, ultimately driverless cars. So the interim step there is follow list cars. Anyway, I know that Dan's trying to distract me from what really is the interim step there is follow this car
That's like the ball going through the net as the seconds take off the clock. That was impressive. That was swish. That's interesting. So sort of what you're suggesting because we hear a lot about driverless cars these days, ultimately driverless cars. So the interim step there is follow list cars. Anyway, I know that Dan's trying to distract me from what really is the interim step there is follow this car|||这就像在倒计时结束时球穿过篮网一样。太惊艳了。太利落了。这很有趣。所以你某种程度上暗示的是，因为我们现在经常听到关于无人驾驶汽车的消息，终极目标是无人驾驶汽车。那么其中的过渡步骤就是跟车……不管怎样，我知道丹正试图分散我的注意力，让我忽视真正的过渡步骤其实是跟着这辆车……
anyway i know that that's trying to distract me from what really is at hand which is he's trying to buy time yeah but i'm not gonna let him do that because at the clock actually starts right now oh man okay so uh... parents one of the things that parents do is they have to watch out what their kids watch on television and movies and so forth so you would never let to chunker your daughter watch pulp Fiction. Of course not. Of course not.
anyway i know that that's trying to distract me from what really is at hand which is he's trying to buy time yeah but i'm not gonna let him do that because at the clock actually starts right now oh man okay so uh... parents one of the things that parents do is they have to watch out what their kids watch on television and movies and so forth so you would never let to chunker your daughter watch pulp Fiction. Of course not. Of course not.|||不管怎样，我知道他是在试图转移我对当前正事的注意力，也就是他在争取时间。是的，但我不会让他得逞，因为时钟实际上从现在开始计时！天哪，好吧……父母们要做的事情之一，就是必须留意孩子们在电视、电影等上面看什么。所以尚卡尔，你绝不会让你的女儿看《低俗小说》。当然不。当然不。
Instead, you would have her watch cartoons or Disney movies. Well, there's a great new study out of the British Medical Journal. Oh, no. Yeah, you got it. Showing, and this are their words, that children's animated films are in fact,
Instead, you would have her watch cartoons or Disney movies. Well, there's a great new study out of the British Medical Journal. Oh, no. Yeah, you got it. Showing, and this are their words, that children's animated films are in fact,|||相反，你会让她看动画片或迪士尼电影。嗯，《英国医学杂志》最近发表了一项很棒的新研究。噢，不。是的，你猜对了。该研究显示，用他们的话说，儿童动画电影实际上是……
quote, hotbeds of murder and mayhem. That principal cartoon characters are more than twice as likely to be killed off as their counterparts in films for adults. Oh my God. The parents of main characters were five times more likely to die in children's cartoons as they were in films aimed at adults. So what we have is that instead of having, by protecting our kids from so-called violent films, we're sticking them in front of kids fair that are at some level terrifying.
quote, hotbeds of murder and mayhem. That principal cartoon characters are more than twice as likely to be killed off as their counterparts in films for adults. Oh my God. The parents of main characters were five times more likely to die in children's cartoons as they were in films aimed at adults. So what we have is that instead of having, by protecting our kids from so-called violent films, we're sticking them in front of kids fair that are at some level terrifying.|||引述一下，“谋杀和混乱的温床”。主角卡通人物在电影中被杀害的可能性是成人电影中同类角色的两倍多。天哪。在儿童动画片中，主要角色的父母死去的可能性是面向成人的电影中的五倍。所以我们得到的结果是，我们本意是通过保护孩子免受所谓暴力电影的侵害，结果却把他们塞到了在某种程度上令人恐惧的儿童节目面前。
It's a bloodbath these cartoons and animated films are. Oh my gosh. And the sad part of your study, Dan, is that you came in right under the wire, so I didn't get the pleasure of buzzing you. I'm handing the stopwatch and time or back to Dan. I'm gonna try and find out if I can beat my own record the last time of finishing it. Nevermind. It's not about you, Shankar. It's about understanding science. I'm gonna try and find out if I can beat my own record the last time of finishing 59 seconds. It's not about you, Shankar. It's about understanding science. So don't feel too much pressure here, even though there is a clock ticking down.
It's a bloodbath these cartoons and animated films are. Oh my gosh. And the sad part of your study, Dan, is that you came in right under the wire, so I didn't get the pleasure of buzzing you. I'm handing the stopwatch and time or back to Dan. I'm gonna try and find out if I can beat my own record the last time of finishing it. Nevermind. It's not about you, Shankar. It's about understanding science. I'm gonna try and find out if I can beat my own record the last time of finishing 59 seconds. It's not about you, Shankar. It's about understanding science. So don't feel too much pressure here, even though there is a clock ticking down.|||这些动画片简直就是血流成河。天哪。丹，你这项研究令人遗憾的部分在于，你刚好在最后关头过关，所以我没有享受到按下蜂鸣器的快感。我把秒表和计时器交还给丹。我要试着看看能否打破我上次59秒完成的记录。没关系。这与你无关，尚卡尔。这是关于理解科学。我要试着看看能否打破我上次59秒完成的记录。这与你无关，尚卡尔。这是关于理解科学。所以这里不要有太大压力，尽管倒计时钟正在滴答作响。
So here we go. We, Shankar, you're one minute. If you can handle it, start right now. All right, so we've given parents three things to think about today. Three ways in which they are messing up their children. And just to make sure that we're leaving them with a nice, even number, I'm gonna add a fourth idea to this. There's a lot of research that's been done that looks at why young girls often seem to perform better than young boys in school.
So here we go. We, Shankar, you're one minute. If you can handle it, start right now. All right, so we've given parents three things to think about today. Three ways in which they are messing up their children. And just to make sure that we're leaving them with a nice, even number, I'm gonna add a fourth idea to this. There's a lot of research that's been done that looks at why young girls often seem to perform better than young boys in school.|||好了，我们开始吧。尚卡尔，你的一分钟。如果你能应付的话，现在就开始。好的，今天我们已经给父母们提出了三件需要思考的事情。他们搞砸孩子的三个途径。为了确保我们给他们留下一个整齐的偶数，我打算在这个基础上再加第四个观点。有大量研究探讨了为什么年轻女孩在学校的表现往往似乎比小男孩更好。
And a couple of economists decided to look at three countries, the United States, the United Kingdom, and Canada, and they find there are many reasons that this could be happening, but one important reason might be the behavior of their parents. It turns out parents systematically spend more time with their daughters doing cognitive activities than they do with their sons.
And a couple of economists decided to look at three countries, the United States, the United Kingdom, and Canada, and they find there are many reasons that this could be happening, but one important reason might be the behavior of their parents. It turns out parents systematically spend more time with their daughters doing cognitive activities than they do with their sons.|||几位经济学家决定研究三个国家：美国、英国和加拿大，他们发现这种情况发生的原因有很多，但其中一个重要原因可能是他们父母的行为。事实证明，父母系统性地花更多时间陪伴女儿进行认知活动，而不是儿子。
And in fact, when the economists measure the disparity in the amount of time parents spend with their daughters and with their sons, the extent of this disparity seems to match, correlate with the disparity that we see in early test scores between young boys and young girls. In other words, here's one more reason if you're a parent, especially the parent of young boys, for you to blame yourself. Well, you're well and under the wire here. So this is very heartening for me, Shankar, because as someone who's a bad driver and a poor student, it's not my fault now. It's all my parents fault. who's a bad driver and a poor student, it's not my fault now, it's all my parents fault. On that happy note, Dan Pink is the author of Drive, several other books about human behavior, Dan thanks for joining us today. Always a pleasure.
And in fact, when the economists measure the disparity in the amount of time parents spend with their daughters and with their sons, the extent of this disparity seems to match, correlate with the disparity that we see in early test scores between young boys and young girls. In other words, here's one more reason if you're a parent, especially the parent of young boys, for you to blame yourself. Well, you're well and under the wire here. So this is very heartening for me, Shankar, because as someone who's a bad driver and a poor student, it's not my fault now. It's all my parents fault. who's a bad driver and a poor student, it's not my fault now, it's all my parents fault. On that happy note, Dan Pink is the author of Drive, several other books about human behavior, Dan thanks for joining us today. Always a pleasure.|||事实上，当经济学家衡量父母花在女儿和儿子身上的时间差距时，这种差距的程度似乎与我们在年轻男孩和女孩的早期考试成绩中看到的差距相吻合、相关。换句话说，如果你是一个父母，特别是小男孩的父母，这里又多了一个你可以责备自己的理由。嗯，你这次很好地在规定时间内完成了。所以这对我来说非常鼓舞人心，尚卡尔，因为作为一个开车技术差、学生时代成绩不好的差生，现在这不是我的错了。这全是我父母的错。作为一个开车技术差、学生时代成绩不好的差生，现在这不是我的错了，这全是我父母的错。伴随着这个愉快的小插曲，丹尼尔·平克是《驱动力》及其他几本关于人类行为的书籍的作者，丹，谢谢你今天加入我们。始终是我的荣幸。
This was another episode of Stop What Science. For more of the Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook and Twitter at HiddenBrain and at HiddenBrain.npr.org. We want your questions and ideas for future episodes. Do you have a story that you think might reveal something interesting about human nature? Email us at HiddenBrain.NPR.org with Story in the subject line. The Hidden Brain is produced by Kara Magar-Kalasin. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. his NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
This was another episode of Stop What Science. For more of the Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook and Twitter at HiddenBrain and at HiddenBrain.npr.org. We want your questions and ideas for future episodes. Do you have a story that you think might reveal something interesting about human nature? Email us at HiddenBrain.NPR.org with Story in the subject line. The Hidden Brain is produced by Kara Magar-Kalasin. I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. his NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||这是另一期“秒表科学”节目。欲了解更多《隐性大脑》的内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注@HiddenBrain，或访问HiddenBrain.npr.org。我们期待您对未来节目的问题和想法。你是否有一个你认为能揭示人类有趣一面的故事？请发邮件至HiddenBrain.NPR.org，并在主题栏中注明“Story”。《隐性大脑》由卡拉·马加尔-卡拉辛制作。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。